[Musica]
i movimenti dell'inchino possono
liberare energie creative nell'uomo
questa è la mia domanda oggi
cos'è l'aikido lo scopriremo assieme
prima lasciatemi ricordare le parole di
una donna il cui pensiero fu
rivoluzionario e senza te
maria montessori scrive amano e lo
strumento dell'umano intelligenza vorrei
aggiungere che anche il tutto il corpo
nero strumento per contro osserviamo
come spesso semi esposti ad attività che
considerano scarsamente non sto corpo il
ruolo centrale che ha nello sviluppo
cognitivo
anche le neuroscienze oggi riconoscono
come il movimento del corpo influenza
direttamente il nostro cervello
il cervello viene letteralmente plasmato
dal nostro parigi della cosiddetta
cognizione infortunata
in altre parole corpo e mente sono un
unico come da millenni insegnano maestri
e saggi il corpo per l'espressione
visibile del nostro essere il corpo come
linguaggio fatto di gesti posture
movimenti tensioni
io sono come il mio corpo si muove
[Musica]
[Applauso]
io
all
[Musica]
cosa genera il movimento
cosa muove l'essere umano
cosa lo spinge ad agire ad esprimere la
propria energia vitale
forse è la risposta ad una condizione
esterna
seae anche e non è solo questo
la vera scintilla
è bisogno innato dell'uomo
a cambiare a conoscere a trovare nuovi
modi per relazionarsi
l'uomo energia e bisogno di manifestarla
attraverso l'attivazione del proprio
corpo
l'essere tramite un corpo nel suo
ambiente
ma l'energia non scorre dove ci sono
blocchi
dove i muscoli sono rigidi
quando siamo incastrati nelle nostre
paure ansie ai piccoli certezze
eppure basterebbe poco basterebbe sapere
che i blocchi si possono superare che in
realtà sono ostacoli autogenerati da
nostri errate convinzioni
iniziamo dal nostro corpo
liberiamo il movimento
[Musica]
noi
[Applauso]
[Musica]
rispondiamo alla domanda che cos'è
lettino
è un'arte marziale
concepita per essere budo giapponesi un
sistema educativo
un sistema che attraverso il paradigma
dal confronto marziale ed uno strumento
il nostro corpo insegno suo messaggio di
pancia
superare i conflitti senza evitare il
confronto cercando lo vede risposte
dentro e fuori di noi
senza vincitori e sconfitti
e la pratica delle chiedo i due corpi
dialogano continuamente per trovare
nuovi equilibri nel movimento
e un sistema di apprendimento mediato
dal corpo ed ha mai me che insegna i
suoi messaggi spirituali volte a
ricercare l'armonia
richiedo significa questo via del
lighting via dell'armonia e l'armonia e
quella capacità di mantenere equilibrio
e serenità anche nei momenti più
difficili nei momenti più fluidi e
continuo cambiamento
[Musica]
[Applauso]